alors alain stephen bonsoir et publié
avant l'été voyage au coeur de la
scientologie le témoignage d'un ex
disciple aux éditions privé et le procès
de la scientologie cette semaine a remis
votre livre en pleine lumière alors ce
soir on a un bouddhiste on a un
scientologue il ya un point commun quand
même entre vos deux croyances c'est que
vous avez tom cruise vous avez richard
geere eux ils ont travolta vous allez
sharon stone
nous les cathos en à bigard et
bernadette chirac
[Musique]
alors un sofa de rebond soir le tribunal
a condamné la scientologie cette semaine
mais n'a pas pu la dissoudre la loi
avait été modifiée en douce on parle
dans les milieux politiques d'erreurs
techniques est-ce que vous pensez que
l'état est infiltré à ce point par les
scientologues qu'on puisse faire changer
une loi qu'on puisse corriger une loi ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que le loi du 12
mai donc en question fait 700 pages donc
ça a dû se passer dans les bureaux
maintenant il ya quand même un fait
extrêmement troublant c'est que
le 8 juillet
donc suite à un mail qui a été envoyé à
un journaliste américain donc là on a su
que l'avocat américain de la
scientologie donc worlds était déjà au
courant de cette modification alors
qu'ici en france les personnes
concernées ne l'était pas encore donc
c'est un fake extrêmement troublant
extrêmement troublant aussi le fait que
nicolas sarkozy ait reçu très longuement
tom cruise lors de son dernier passage à
paris très troublant aussi ce que
raconte le canard enchaîné cette semaine
à savoir qu'il ya de moins en moins de
policiers qui travaillent sur la
scientologie on leur a dit bon écoute et
occupez-vous un peu d'autres choses donc
il ya plus une brigade qui dédié à la
scientologie voilà alors on parlait des
stars et vous cessez chick corea que
vous aimez beaucoup qui vous a amené à
vous intéresser à la scientologie non on
est en 85 j'avais 24 ans et
un jour j'assiste à un concert de chick
corea et c'est la découverte de cette
musique le jazz pour moi c'est une
véritable révélation j'y crois et
devient un vrai modèle pour moi je
découvre par la suite qu'il est
scientologue jeu fait la rencontre d'un
autre musicien qui devient très bons
amis et qui est lui me dit voilà donc
moi je suis scientologues aussi et c'est
par ce biais là que je suis rentré donc
à l'époque vous occupiez d'enfants
handicapés pendant les semaines et vous
enseigner la musique le week-end faste
en belgique et là vous avez vous
installé à paris pour travailler à
l'école du rythme qui est en fait une
cellule officieuse de recrutement de la
scientologie il savait que je voulais
faire une carrière artistique qui savait
qu'elle j'avais une admiration folle
pour tic horaire donc quand thomas
présente un job ou dans une école qui
travaillent sur le métal sur lequel
avait travaillé chick corea c'est
intimement persuadé que c'était un
cadeau qui était tombé dépensier
réellement à l'époque que la
scientologie allez vous épanouir
artistiquement complètement comme l ipad
oui disons chick corea en ce qui vous
concerne vous découvrez dans cette école
du rythme que tous les professeurs tous
les directeurs sont scientologues vous
lisez le livre de renaud barde la
dianétique qui est donc le livre
fondateur de la scientologie alors dans
la dianétique on dit qu'il ya 75
millions d'années un univers organisée
en une confédération galactique de 76
planète dirigée par un homme exe nous
aurait envoyé sur terre par fuzer 13.5
crillon d'habitants avant de soude et
leur âme à l'aide de bombes h pour
fabriquer d'été tant de corps là vous
n'êtes pas tiqué quand on vous a raconté
sa non pour ce monstre email à ce que
vous annoncez là c'est quelque chose qui
est en fait confidentiel c'est pas du
tout dans le livre la dianétique c'est
une information auquel j'aie jamais
accès c'est quelque chose que j'ai
appris une fois que j'étais sorti donc
c'est en fait quelque chose qui est
confidentiel et ça fait partie de la
doctrine qu'on apprend quand on est
vraiment à un très haut niveau
un niveau auquel j'aie jamais jamais
accès c'est à dire qu en pourcentage
c'est vrai qu'il ya peut-être un demi
pour cent des scientologues qui arrive à
ce niveau là parce que nous on a un mec
qui marche sur l'eau mais franchement je
le savais pas que les gens étaient prêts
à gober beaucoup plus mais apparemment
oui moi ça me fait penser moi l usage
des médicaments frauduleux en fait on
met la vie des gens en danger en vendant
des choses qui sont faites pour les
sauver c'est un peu le même système
c'est vrai c'est pire que madoff parce
qu'en plus on a présenté ça comme
quelque chose qui a donné un sens à
votre existence est ce que vous saviez
que la scientologie avait été créé par
un écrivain de science-fiction dénommé
ron à bardin il ya un autre écrivain de
science-fiction qui lui a très bien
réussi que ça plaise harlan ellison
grands auteurs
qui a raconté qu'un jour il était avec
ron bard des doutes copains écrivain de
science fiction
et que renault barde se plaignaient de
ne pas gagner d'argent il ya un type qui
lui a dit pourquoi tu inventes pas une
religion c'est quand même extraordinaire
il a dit je vais le faire il l'a fait
quitter par dessus tout quelqu'un
d'extrêmement d'heure déranger parce
qu'il ya des expertises du temps où il
était dans l' us navy c'est vrai que les
expertises psychiatriques sont cassés on
catégorique c'est quelqu'un vraiment
qu'il y avait un réel problème pour moi
la seule la scientologie n'est rien
d'autre qu'un délire sans sectionnait
skunk l on a mélangé ou aux gardes à
mélanger quelques principes
réglementaires de psychanalyse or leur
truc c'est quoi ces souhaite prendre des
gens qui sont pas bien en leur
promettant de les reconstruire soit
prendre des gens qui vont bien il est
cassé avant de les reconstruire en gros
c'est ça le truc non c'est surtout la
deuxième la deuxième option vous et vous
ne vous encaissez complètement les
premiers cours confesse on découvre
qu'ils sont super intéressant moi j'ai
fait un petit cours de communication un
stage pratique de semaine de travail 350
francs très peu cher avec un énorme
résultat à la clé qui était le fait que
j'avais beaucoup moins de traque et pour
moi c'est important donc du coup ça
installe sacrément la confiance oui
j'étais intimement persuadé que j'étais
arrivé dans un endroit où il y avait un
profond respect de l'individualité où on
dit que les artistes ces gens
extrêmement important je me souviens
avoir eu cette phrase qui m'avait
normand touché c'est une grandeur d'une
culture
se mesure à ses rêves et ses rêves son
rêvé par des artistes on est dans une
phase de séduction le but c'est
d'appâter pour mieux ferrer pour moi je
n'ai jamais adhéré à la scientologie en
pleine connaissance de cause rien dire
quand j'ai fait mon premier chèque je ne
savais pas la porter jusqu'à un an au
début évidemment on sait pas très cher
50 français ça fait même pas 10 euros
mais pour arriver au dernier niveau qui
s'appelle haute et 8 là ça peut aller
jusqu'à 400 mille euros pendant il ya
une quinzaine de niveaux à franchir donc
qu'ils se font par l'intermédiaire d'une
part des cours des formations et d'autre
part par un travail qu'on fait un tête à
tête avec un praticien et donc si on
veut aller au plus haut niveau dans
doctrine mans c'est tout le parcours
coûte au moins créé très cher mazovia
l'électromètre qui est une machine qui
est destiné à détecter les cassures
remontant à une vie antérieure
incroyable en fait c'est un homme m
c'est un truc qui coûte rien ils le
vendent 3800 euros mais bondées comment
une telle entreprise peut-elle plus
poursuit si longtemps comment les
mesures ne sont pas plus sévères sénat
peine concevable alors après quand vous
payez pas il ya un truc qui s'appelle le
webdoc committee alors ça c'est terrible
c'est à dire qu'on fait c'est des hommes
de main de la direction internationale
qui viennent vous dire écoutez vous
devez du pognon faut nous le donner
c'est là le ton change l'heure n'est
plus dans la sympathie rien du tout là
il ya un mec vous l'entendez une fois
qu'il dit je veux ce [ __ ] de l'argent
incroyable alors vous épouser une jeune
scientologues et très rapidement elle
commença à écrire des rapports de
délation contre vous c'est à dire qu'en
fait vous êtes complètement noyauté vous
découvrez un jour ça c'est le comble
qu'il existe à votre sujet un programme
pour manier alain stoffel c'est un mode
d'emploi pour vous manipulez en fait
complètement dans ce programme il y
avait 19 points qui étaient très précis
est un des points c'est fait venir alain
stéphane dans une pièce et
installez-vous de telle façon qu'ils ne
puissent plus sortir à l'époque
il me réclamait cent treize mille francs
que je refusais de payer et donc l'idée
c'est que donc on avait ordonné une
séquestration et le but c'est de me
soumettre à un chantage abject pour me
faire cracher cracher cet argent là non
mais voilà après ça se termine dans
l'extorsion de fond complètement ce qui
est extrêmement fort c'est que quand on
est dans la scientologie et quand je dis
extrêmement fort je veux dire c'est là
où c'est extrêmement pervers non c'est
moi pendant les 15 ans j'étais en
scientologie j'étais intimement persuadé
que je pensais de plus en plus par moi
même et que j'étais de plus en plus
authentique alors que c'était tout un
verre ce qui se passait à l'époque
j'avais vraiment l'impression d'être
heureux dedans mais aujourd'hui avec le
recul je sais que j étais heureux mais
pas plus qu'un alcoolique lobotomisés
qui doit quitter rennes comme parce que
quand quilit-quilit les livres vous avez
été très courageux quand même non
parce que vous êtes quand même un en
publiant ce bouquin vous êtes dresser
contre cette organisation
c'est à dire qu'à partir du moment où
j'ai fait la découverte de deux de ce
dossier dans lequel j'ai trouver encore
d'autres pièces où j'ai vu que que
j'avais été flic et et que les moindres
détails de la vie privée est tout ça
c'était consignés et donc c'est là que
j'ai vu que que l'ensemble des pressions
des menaces que j'avais subi et tout ce
qui m'avait été préjudiciable en fait
c'était pas le résultat de dérives
individuelles mais c'était bien de la
mise en application des règlements
visent découvert le pot-aux-roses oui
ils ont attaqué votre bouquin quand je
suis sorti
j'ai tout de suite porté plainte ce avec
eux et ils se sont fait pas fait
attendre parce qu'ils ont une force de
frappe extrêmement redoutable parce qu'à
partir du moment où on attaque la
scientologie on devient ce qu'ils
appellent dans leur jargon une personne
suppressive c'est-à-dire un ennemi à
abattre en 2001 par exemple lors d'un
dans une convention internationale un
des plus grands pontes de la
scientologie avait clairement annoncé
que donc qu'ils savaient pour l'année
2001 il avait donc descendu les espy
donc c'est l'abréviation de personnes
suppressive donc des gens comme moi
comme démarre dans une canard et je cite
je suis textos et qu'il y avait encore
un grand nettoyage à faire et donc à
partir le mans ou moi j'ai porté plainte
forcément je suis devenu un ennemi à
abattre j'étais poursuivi donc ils ont
porté plainte contre moi parce que ils
le font de façon absolument légale en
eau dans d'autres termes aucune de nos
plans des ongles et fait illégalement et
moi pendant cinq ans j'ai été traîné
devant les tribunaux donc ces
dénonciations calomnieuses fraude
fiscale fraude à l'urssaf et donc la
syrie a été très longue pendant cinq ans
j'ai enfin ça a été l'horreur quoi le
but c'était vraiment de me pousser dans
donc avant de tirer une balle dans la
tête face qu'il vient vraiment de 2 et
pensé au suicide est un moment
d'ailleurs oui c'est incroyable parce
que quand on attaque la scientologie
j'ai vu ça nouveau jt leur seule défense
et de dire c'est un procès en hérésie
c'est de ce discours qui maintient mais
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que qui
s'affiche église c'est pas parce que moi
je dis aujourd'hui que je suis le pape
que ma voiture va se transformer en
papamobile en fait depuis le début la
scientologie essaye de mettre le débat à
leur sujet sur le domaine de la sphère
du religieux
religiosité pour eux en fait ce n'est
rien d'autre qu'un alibi parce que
pascal intérêt il ya rien de religieux
ce qu'il faut dire aussi c'est que
renault barda transformer son
organisation en religion pour pas payer
d'impôts aussi parce que c'était
s'unissent et comme cette veste ou sac
aux états unis et ils disent qu'ils sont
reconnus aux états unis comme une
religion ce qui est pipeau en fait quand
ils communiquent là dessus tout le monde
pense qu'ils sont reconnus aux états
unis comme une congrégation en fait il
ne s'agit que d'une simple
reconnaissance fiscale pour échapper à
la fiscalité moi la
besoin de plus d'altruisme notre société
et voir des gens qui sciemment nuisent
aux autres le dire c'est une tristesse à
assinie semblables c'est terrible
absolument terrible bien là merci entre
le capot moteur
les corrections de ne rien rater de
l'inhabituelle abonnez vous il m'était
impossible